- [Voiceover] There is a lot
of content on Khan Academy,
especially in math and science,
and we're continuing to add
more and more content everyday
in math and science and in other areas
like history and art
history and wherever else.
But I want to do in this
video is make sense of
some potential progressions,
especially in math and science.
And see how all of these
different topics relate
to each other in ways that
we can use Khan Academy.
In blue here, I have a
proposed math progression.
So we have a mission on Khan Academy,
it's called early math, it's
also called the K-2 mission.
When I talk about missions, this is where
you take a diagnostic and
based on that it starts
recommending things and then
there are master challenges,
all of these game
mechanics, and you can work
at your own time and pace.
You can also access these,
what we call in library mode,
where you can just pick and choose
which exercises you want to practice,
or which videos or articles
you want to take a look at.
What I recommend a student
do, if they haven't already,
master the early learning mission,
finish that all the way
to one hundred percent,
then do third grade,
fourth grade, fifth grade,
sixth grade and then seventh grade.
Once you start getting into the
sixth and seventh grade range,
you're starting to do a
little bit of pre-algebra.
And as you see, once you
get past seventh grade,
a whole new world starts to open up.
So once you get past seventh
grade, you start getting into
some real algebra and my map here
starts to get a little more complex.
But what you see going on here is,
you have an algebra basics mission,
and the idea of that, that's
actually a bit of a subset
of what you would see in the eighth grade
algebra one, algebra two missions,
although there's a few
extra things relative
to the eighth grade mission.
But it's the very core of algebra,
and you can see that if you
were to finish that mission
all sorts of extra things open up.
Now if you want to know your algebra
more comprehensibly, and
I encourage you to do so,
you should complete the
eighth grade mission,
the algebra one mission and
the algebra two missions.
And what you'll see is if you finish
the algebra basics mission,
the eighth grade mission
isn't that much incremental
work or vice versa.
And if you finish these
and the algebra one mission
isn't that much incremental work,
it gives you credit
for where they overlap.
And if you finish these
three, the algebra two mission
isn't that much incremental work.
But if you were to do this collection,
you have a really solid
foundation for algebra
and all sorts of things start
to become available for you.
If you're going to do the
algebra basics mission,
you are fairly well
equipped to start thinking
about things like finance
and capital markets,
microeconomics, macroeconomics.
If you do the algebra basics mission
you're also ready for biology,
a lot of biology doesn't
have mathematics in it,
but there is some algebra once
you start getting in to biology.
In fact there some
probability and statistics,
some basics probability and statistics
once you start getting
into things like genetics.
So I encourage you to have that
nice foundation in algebra.
Chemistry too, there
isn't math throughout it,
there isn't algebra throughout it,
there actually is math
throughout chemistry,
but the algebra will help you go into,
you will start seeing
some types of problems
where you will have to solve
a quadratic or things like that.
So it is useful to have a
solid foundation in algebra.
If you want to go into physics,
this is where the algebra,
the physics on Khan Academy is
currently non-calculus based,
we're going to add calculus based soon,
but in order to engage with it,
you have to have a very
solid foundation in algebra,
that's where this arrow comes from,
and you need to know the
basics of trigonometry,
that's why I drew this dotted arrow.
You should know what a sine,
cosine, tangent of angles are,
and the kind of right triangle definitions
or the unit circle definitions
of those trig functions,
and that's just the very
basics of trigonometry.
But once you know that,
the basics of algebra,
the basics of trigonometry,
you're ready to engage in physics.
And related to physics of course,
and really based on physics,
is cosmology and astronomy.
Once again if you have
the basics of algebra,
you're really ready to start
engaging on that front.
What about math, well
you can just keep going.
If you have the basics of algebra,
you can start going into
probability and statistics
which is also super foundational.
If you were to go to
graduate school one day
or do research in almost anything,
probability and statistics is core.
Frankly, any profession that you go into
there will be a lot of
probability and statistics.
We can keep going, geometry is neat area,
is a neat subject because
not only will you be
studying things we traditionally
associate with geometry,
but it's really the first
domain that you will see where
you're going to think about
proofing things rigorously.
So once you get this good
foundation in algebra and geometry
you're ready to really
dive into trigonometry,
and once you have all of that built out
you can go to calculus.
Which will you find fascinating,
which opens up the world
up multi variable calculus,
differential equations and linear algebra
is typically taken when you're
in college after calculus.
But really to engage in linear algebra
you need a solid foundation in algebra
and a bit of foundation in trigonometry.
So I encourage you to
go on that progression.
Now we also see things like SAT,
of course the standardized test,
that's a big part of college admissions.
And I encourage you to
engage on the test prep
for the SAT on Khan Academy that
we do in conjunction
with the college board.
Not just because it will
hopefully improve your SAT score,
but the SAT is a measure
of college readiness.
So the better that you're
able to do on this,
this is a solid indicator
of your college readiness.
You can really start to
engage on that SAT practice
as soon as you have a solid
foundation of the algebra.
So as soon as you have the
algebra basics mission done,
I encourage you to go
into the SAT mission.
To really engage in
everything on the SAT mission,
especially on the math
side or the SAT prep,
I encourage you to also
get through the algebra two
because there are going
to be some functions
and the other pieces here
that I haven't talked about.
Here are the programming,
and you can start programming
on Khan Academy for those
of you who haven't seen it
it's a lot of fun, you
get to work on projects
and share it with your friends,
and there's even a peer review mechanism.
You can start engaging with
that at a fairly early level.
Once you have some of
your core arithmetic done,
but obviously the more math
you have behind you the better.
But then once you get through
some of these core subjects
that we've been talking about,
especially basic algebra,
the very basics of trigonometry then
you can start going into
advanced JavaScript.
And algorithms.
Advanced JavaScript
you'll especially enjoy
because here you can do
simulations of nature,
simulations of some of
the things you will learn
in these science topics.
Or you can really start
to make video games.
Hopefully this gives you a
good sense of what's available,
especially on the math,
science side of Khan Academy.
And in a way that you
can progress through it.
And if you really, all of these things,
the things in blue from early math
all the way through calculus,
there are missions for.
So all of this stuff right over here,
there's these missions for which are these
interactive, give you as
many exercises as you need,
all of these game mechanics,
SAT also has an interactive tool for,
but the things where we
don't have missions yet,
I encourage you to go through the videos,
go one by one, if I'm going to go work,
or whoever in the video who
is doing a work example,
try to pause the video and see
if you can do it on your own.
If you see me do it, look at
the video then stop the video
and try to do that work over again,
do the exercises there, I
think you'll be surprised
by how much you can actually learn.
We get a lot of testimonials every day,
from people all walks of life
who thought that they
weren't good at math,
or who thought they
weren't good at science,
but when they worked step by step,
they build their foundations,
they go back to any gaps
that they might have,
over and over again people are surprised
by how much they are
actually able to progress.
And just as a reminder, this
isn't all the content on
Khan Academy, we have some
great content on the humanities,
history, art history, we're adding
a whole set of partner content,
and we're working on a
whole bunch of things
as we speak, so enjoy.